[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young
woman whose fiance is seeing somebody
else
we talked to a new husband who just
found out his wife has a whole bunch of
secrets
when we talk to a woman whose ex-husband
is trying to take away her baby
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john delony's show
thanks for joining us today we're glad
to have you we talking about
mental health relationships um i don't
know what else
education's food sadness
workout whatever's going on in your
hearts and mind you can make it up we
could probably talk about your car
i'm not really impressive when it comes
to mechanics skills
i do have nunchuck skills and
what is that pegs shocks look like
lucky remember what was that movie a
napoleon dynamite
yeah man your producer of the year james
hey
i may not have caught that reference
right away but i do own a pair of actual
nunchucks
do you you oh you own a pair of actu
like can you use them
yeah i can use them well cool so what's
going to happen next show and you heard
it here first ladies and gentlemen
i'm going to play the recorder while you
do a num chuck routine
on camera i will set a reminder to bring
them tomorrow it's going to be
incredible
good folks you want to stay tuned you're
probably going to want to cut the
podcast off which is going to make the
podcast folks
sad and you're going to want to catch
this next show on youtube whenever it
airs
but since james owns quote unquote
creative control of the editing process
the chances of this seeing light of day
are small quite small
not gonna happen zach will make sure it
happens though
dude what if we had a recorder nunchuck
fight
you came at me i would i would
lull you to sleep with my uh
powers since i own the recorder that
you're gonna use i
might um put poison on the tip of it it
was a
well-played power move
since i owned the recorder i see what
you did there hey so if you want to be
on that particular episode where
james and i battle numchucks vs recorder
or any other episode give us a shout
at 1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
i can already tell by how high she's
raising her eyebrows that kelly's going
to skip the next few episodes just
because
just because maybe
especially that one do you want to fight
you can join the fight too
no i want nothing to do with it to be
honest i'll kick both your ears anyway
funner.com.net.org
all right let's go straight to the
phones let's go to
delia in california delia what's up
hi dr dalony how are you so much for
taking my call
thank you so much for calling hey listen
okay listen with as a guy whose last
name rhymes with an unprocessed i mean
just a gross lunch meat
um i'm all about good name jokes
what's the best name joke you've heard
related to your name
delia um do people say like hey what's
the deal you delia
is that like about as good as it i
actually have heard that one once
just once actually most of the time
people say delilah which
surprises me sometimes
delilah is it because they can't read
probably all right so
you have better friends than i do that
you only heard that one time good for
you
i need to start hanging out with better
people all right so what's up julia how
can i help
okay um so
my and i have been together
six and a half years uh before that we
were like best friends for about four or
five years so we've been in each other's
lives for
10 11 years now got engaged
october 2019 and four months away from
getting married this october october 9th
which is actually my birthday
october night 2021. happy birthday
um well i don't know we'll see how
um oh okay so we found out
just found out last week that he was
actually seeing someone else
um and i'm very devastated of course
and heartbroken and so do you have no
idea no it was a
complete surprise because i mean i
thought a relationship was you know
great of course
you know we live together so you have
your oh take out the trash and your
little fights here and there but
it was not i wouldn't say it was a rocky
relationship where i saw anything like
this coming
up i i never it was a complete shocker
to me
how did you find out
so last sunday
oh this is last sunday like you just
found out just just just found out
yes wow okay this is happening right now
so you're we are live and on scene okay
so last sunday okay go ahead
yes last sunday since we have find my
friends you know on iphones
he was visiting his mom i was visiting
my family
and i was just you know whenever you
head back because we live together
let me head back like let me know i'll
head back at the same time
and he lied to me he's like oh like yeah
i'm gonna leave soon
um and i looked at his location just to
see if he left already but he was
already
in towns but somewhere else so i knew he
was you know lying to me about where he
was so that
day i told him like where's you know
where
are you when i'm chanting my calls he
was
he just said okay well we're gonna talk
tonight and then
so sunday we get home and he basically
tells me he has cold feet
but he doesn't say why he doesn't tell
me what he's doing he just says like you
know it's a big step i don't know if
i can be a good husband and
blah blah and it was all just very huge
surprise to me so that night
i was just i had a hunch you know where
is this coming from
and i looked through his phone and
that's when i saw all the messages and
calls and
that's when everything came out
wow so there's a lot here
um so what has the last few days been
like
terrible yeah
i found out and then he told me you know
the truth
that which is good he was
really honest it's also terrible because
just knowing all the details
really hurts um so someone he works
with so he would lie about working late
um and they were basically dating each
other you know going out to eat
going to parks he's going over to
her place um and
yeah and so these last few days
was very confusing because one day he
said
it's over between me and her like i want
to be with you we're going to get
married we're going to get through this
we're going to make it work
and of course that's what i wanted to
hear because i was willing to
forgive him and do anything we could go
to therapy anything
because i i love him and i want to be
with him
but then he changed his mind to i'm
confused like i think i need time
for myself and
um then the next day he's back to
um you know we're gonna you're gonna be
my wife we're gonna make this work
and now most recently it's back to
like i need time for myself and
yeah so here's the thing
um you are right square in the middle of
a forest fire
right um when you
how old are you i'm 25.
yeah so this guy's been part of your
life for basically half of it right
yep nearly half and
um you are in full
you are fully limbic right now you are a
fight or flight and you have not even
begun to
feel this thing yet okay and so
um you may have heard me say this a
bunch and i'll just keep saying it
nobody nobody makes good decisions
when they're in the middle of a
firestorm unless they've trained
specifically for that moment
okay so this isn't the moment to decide
i still love him and we're gonna figure
this out this isn't the moment to decide
get out of here this is a moment for you
to
grieve and you gotta grieve right now
without him giving you his
insights and changing his mind and
toggling back and forth because he's
busted and caught
okay and his whole world is coming down
around him too
i cannot wrap my head or i mean whatever
man
that's a whole other conversation uh
maybe i can talk to him someday
but you're gonna have to either separate
yourself from him from
for a season or he's gonna have to move
out for a season okay
but you've been playing house for a long
time y'all have basically been married
for a long time just waiting on this um
show
and the ceremony and
so you're gonna have to get some time
apart from one another can you can he go
live somewhere else for a season sounds
like he can go live with his mom for a
while right
yeah he actually did definitely
okay this yesterday two days ago
yeah um but the thing is i think he's
still
talking to her listen listen listen
guarantee you he is there is not a
doubt in my mind that he is
a million billion percent chance he is
still talking to her
he's probably seen her okay
there is nothing before or since
that would give me any other um
idea okay
yeah and you said
um he came clean and told me the truth
and
about this person he met at work you all
have a relationship this is just in
10 seconds of you explaining this story
to me where you track each other's
phones
you check his phone when he's because
you don't believe him
he's lied about stuff there's some
definite cracks in the foundation of
this relationship
and who knows how long it's been going
on who knows how how
often he's seen somebody else if it's
the first time the 10th
who knows but right now you got to get
outside of the burning house
okay and what i want you to do is to
take
a breather for a minute and let him know
he's not welcome back in the house
for 30 days at the earliest
and i want you to take some time to
whoo actually feel what's going on
and probably that's gonna look like you
waking up every day
writing him a letter on how you feel
that day you
pieces son of a i cannot believe you
fill in the blank
i've know and what you're going to do is
you're going to start writing this stuff
out you're going to write down how you
feel what you think about him
what you think about yourself all what
do you think about other women all that
stuff's got to come out
and what you're probably going to
uncover is there's been cracks in this
thing for a long time
it's hard for me to believe is somebody
who's
you've got trust issues with him no
i want to say i didn't but since you're
mentioning the whole tracking
thing there is something that's been in
your heart and mind for a long time
and it may just be that's just the way
guys are or he just
talks to somebody or he just works late
or he just goes and visit
something tells me this doesn't just pop
up and that's where you got to
real you didn't want to see it you
wanted to be married you wanted to be
his wife you picked this guy
out half your lifetime ago
and if you go mining right if you start
writing this stuff out and you do it on
a regular basis get somebody with you to
talk
about this not someone's just going to
be like oh just forgive him and move on
he's so cute
and not just burn his house down but not
not somebody who will do that because
that's nonsense
right that's just someone who's putting
gas on your emotional fires but
somebody's going to sit there and listen
to you
and poke and prod and go hey we've known
this for a while
or this blows my mind i really know this
guy i think this is a one-time thing and
whatever someone is going to be honest
with you and let you process openly you
may have to pay this person maybe a
counselor of some sort right
but you're gonna have to get to the
bottom of your
feelings underneath the emotions
underneath what's the truth here and
what's the reality
and you're gonna have to have some space
and you're gonna probably cry like you
have not cried in your whole life
and you're gonna ache and hurt like you
haven't ached and hurt
and you need to come up with a picture
of what life might look like four months
from now and you're not married to this
guy
not to say that's gonna happen but you
need to begin to own this might be part
of your future
and you are worth more somebody who's
going to cheat on you and then come back
and say
hey i'm sorry i want to get married and
the next day be like you know what i'm
out
i like her better and then come back the
next time be like
listen let's play an xbox last night i
think you're the one
and then wakes up the next morning it's
like you know what i'm just gonna go by
and see her
and then i'm gonna go stay at my mom's
i'll probably go see her i mean i'll
just it's cool
it's cool you deserve more than that
delia you deserve more than that
okay he deserves more than that but it's
truth telling honesty time for you for
your relationship
he's got to be gone for a while you got
to get some space in your heart and mind
and your soul
you need to get some wisdom around you
not just someone who is going to bark at
you but just get wisdom around you
you have to start writing stuff down 30
days in a row
how are you feeling what do you think
about yourself what do you think about
him what do you think about this
situation what do you think about
building a future on a cracked
foundation
you're gonna have to excavate that old
foundation and build something totally
new
happens all the time i can tell you so
many folks
who've had infidelity and long-term
relationships and they go in and heal
they build something new and it is
stronger than before
but i can tell you this you can't build
something strong on dishonesty
you can't build something strong on
tracking each other's phones
and sneaking around and lying to each
other and you can't build
something permanent on a damaged
foundation
so delia you should have to sit in this
for a bit it's gonna hurt
real bad i'm so so sorry
healing starts today it's gonna be a
long journey
but we'll be thinking about you get some
folks in your life to walk alongside you
all right let's go to mark
in los angeles california what is up
mark
hi there doctor looney thanks for having
me what's up man how are you
i'm doing all right how are you i'm
doing good so how can i help man
so recently i found out that a few years
before meeting my wife she was working
as an escort
and she had kept this a secret from me
and i can understand why she didn't want
me knowing about it
she told me she hated it it's something
she was ashamed of
maybe a little traumatized by it
she did it for the money she had debt
and eventually she got addicted to the
lifestyle
and continued to do it and now we're
married
and we're expecting a baby and i love my
wife
and i want to accept it and move on but
uh
you know it's kind of a tough pill to
swallow and
i'm not even really sure how i should
feel about it and i'm just wondering how
i can
move forward without that image of the
past
painting our relationship and getting in
the way of our marriage
that's a lot brother
that is a lot thanks for sharing that
how long y'all been married
uh only a couple months uh only a few
months huh
and how far along is little baby
uh about 25 weeks 35 weeks
wow okay is it becoming real yet you're
about to be a dad
yeah it's uh definitely real but i'm
excited for it
that's awesome man okay
so you said you don't know how to feel
what you should feel about this so tell
me what do you feel about this
be honest as you can don't lie to me or
yourself or to the 17 or 18 listeners of
the show
i think the first thing i felt was no no
no no
don't don't start with i think how do
you feel
i feel lied to deceived
okay uh maybe jealous okay
hurt angry
yeah what else
i think i i'm sorry i feel
it's definitely got in the way of my
trust
yeah you think yeah yeah
what else
i don't know i think there's just so
many different
things going in my mind i don't know
where to even begin
so just begin
don't overthink it
yeah i'm saying just begin
you're angry you're pissed off you're
heartbroken you're just sad
what kept you from just packing up and
walking out the door
most of us the story we would tell
ourselves is if one day our wife
sat down and said bt dubs i was an
escort before we
um got married but it's all good now
pass the syrup we would the story we
tell ourselves that we'd be like i'm out
of there bro i'm out
you didn't do that how come
uh i love her i mean you've had a good
relationship so far
not the best it's had its rocky points
but well it's built on these
guys it was yeah you know what i mean
so yeah i would imagine it's like saying
man yeah the
the the our boat trip was pretty rocky
and it's like yeah there's big holes in
that boat full of water
could see that um
how long did y'all date before you got
married uh
it's been about a year now okay
and
so you love her you've known her for
about a year
you got married you're having a baby
what do you want to do
i i want to make this relationship work
this is something in her past and i
don't really have a reason
not to i don't really have a reason to
believe it was something that
has happened since we've been together
and she's been good to me and i want to
take care of the family
is she in on this too
yeah she's been 100
how'd you find out
so when we got married we had uh
our own hard drives like our own files
on our computers and we
put them onto one and so just one day i
was going through and i found some old
photos and
uh like messages
from the agencies
what was that feeling like
it was uh like my heart sank
yeah that's when you can feel your
organs fall out of the bottom of your
you know you're just sitting there and
your stomach drops
so so i found out and then i i
asked her about it that night and she
was a little hesitant she didn't want to
talk about it but
since then she's been completely honest
as far as i'm as i know
okay and i think the key here is as far
as you know
okay so here's the reality of your
situation
and it sounds sensational right most of
us don't wake up
and uh the person we married a few
months in lets us know or we find out
that they used to be
um an escort right prostitute
that right um that doesn't usually
happen
but almost always not almost always but
often you wake up and you
find things out about your spouse
they had a pass they didn't tell you
they're full of this they didn't think
to even explain that
they didn't think this was a big deal or
whatever that happens to be
so at the end of the day here's what
you're wrestling with you're wrestling
with
two things one a shattered picture
of the woman you just married the future
mother of your kid
and of this um
this um fantasy of marriage that you had
right and two you're dealing with a
significant violation of trust
so the violation of trust is something
you're gonna have to
lean into be honest about and continue
to work towards healing
right and she's gonna have to understand
that she violated that trust
if you say i forgive you if you say i am
fully in
and i love you and we are moving forward
then you're not going to be able to beat
her up on this deal you're not going to
bring it up when you get mad five years
from now
you're gonna have moments of insecurity
you're gonna have moments of when she's
late coming home
and you're gonna have to choose to not
use those moments as weapons
because you said i forgive you and you
said i'm all in
and as part of the rebuilding trust
process
you're gonna be able to say hey i'm just
checking in you're late coming home
everything good and that she's gonna
know that part of her rebuilding trust
process
is being completely open and not getting
her feelings hurt when you ask her to
check in
okay you got a lot of healing right
and that's going to be frustrating and
hard and messy you're going to stumble
through that but if you're both all in
you're both all
in right the second part of this
is your picture looks all screwed up
right she's not who you thought she was
yeah
right we all have a past right we
weren't all prostitutes but we all have
a past
right that just sounded
bonkers to even say out loud so what
you're gonna have to do is sit down and
with her
and co-create a new picture what this is
gonna look like
right and if you i'm with you
she's a person of value she's worthy of
being loved too
and if she's put her past behind her and
she's moving on
in a committed relationship with you and
you are the
end-all be-all then she deserves
forgiveness and moving on
just like anybody else does
but there's a part of me that says you
don't trust her yet that you're not
ready to paint a whole new picture with
her included in it because she met
right and so that's gonna at those
building a new painting a new picture
together
building a new building and working on
that trust is going to be like an
infinity signal it's going to work
together
you have to keep working on this and
keep working on it and then brother you
just have to grieve
because you got a picture of what was
and it's gone now and now you know
something
new right scales came off your eyes and
now you got a new
new vision of what's what's going
forward and you're going to have to
grieve that man
just be open about it and so
this is going to be hard yet the the
things to do are relatively simple
it's going to be getting up every day
and remembering to respect her and be
kind to her not weaponize her and love
her like she's your wife because she
is like she's the future mother of your
baby which she is
and it's gonna be honest and open about
rebuilding trust
so how does that sound that's not
something you want to do be a part of
yeah you're right that uh that trust is
still hard to get back but
i think at this point uh it's
she is the future so i want to do
anything i can
so you mentioned something earlier you
said uh
you were jealous what does that mean
i um just that image of
that past work it's i think it's getting
in the way of the intimacy
yeah obviously
i wasn't in the picture
is it getting in the way of your
intimacy the you're starting to put
these images in
on loop replay replay how do you measure
up
how many were there where were they i
wonder if she tried this
are you going down that road yeah all of
that
yeah so hey listen
there is no fruit in detail mining
if she sat there and gave you a rundown
of every single trick she ever turned
if she gave you a rundown on the
physical description of every person she
was ever with
it wouldn't make you feel better
and this is going to be part of your
healing process which is to let some of
that stuff go and what you're going to
have to do is practice
practice controlling your thoughts when
you go down those roads
because what's going to lead you to be
highly insecure
highly frustrated never being able to be
in the present moment with her because
the moment that one thought pops in your
head i wonder if she was somebody else
did this or i wonder if i wonder if this
could have
then you are officially not present
anymore and you are somewhere in her
imagined past
right right and so you're gonna have to
work hard that when that image pops in
your head
you say out loud nope and you have
another image ready to go to which is
probably her staring right back at you
but we have this fantasy that if we just
know every detail
all right good it's not true same thing
happened with folks um
you know when somebody takes their own
life they want to know why and what
happened and uh
and you can learn all that stuff it
never takes away that hurt
never takes away that that feeling of
loss right
and how does she respond when you tell
her that you're struggling with
things with thoughts of jealousy and
your imagination runs wild on you
she's pretty understanding uh but
it's not something she really enjoys
talking about
it's gotten a little a little heated
yeah
and uh does it feel good to bring it up
maybe at first but i don't think it ever
ends well
yeah you know what it's like it's like
throwing a punch feels good and if it
connects solid brother
man it feels good for one second
and then you see their look on their
face you see him fall to the
ground and your
takes over right that
don't turn around this whole thing
around and you put yourself
in some sort of superior position and
beat her up with her past
if you say you're all in you're all in
you've got to put your bricks down too
brother you're bricks of insecurity your
bricks are not enough you're bricks of
moral superiority well i never did this
you're right you didn't congratulations
you said i'm all in
right right so in the same way that
you have to rebuild trust with her she's
got to rebuild trust with you
slowly but surely you're gonna have to
relearn how to trust yourself
you're gonna have to relearn how to
treat people
when you get angry you're gonna have to
learn some new behaviors and new skills
ones that where you don't
yell and raise your voice and get all
high and mighty and superior and yeah
yeah yeah well you don't do any of that
and there's gonna be a hard journey for
both of you and
sounds like this is relatively recent
that you found out
this grief's gonna come in waves it's
gonna come in waves just like the last
caller
if y'all are both all in i have no doubt
in my mind y'all can heal from this
grow and make this a powerful part of
your journey
powerful story and there's also no doubt
in my mind that if at any moment one of
you is like
and dips her toe back in the water this
whole boat's gonna flip right over
easy over you get to make that choice
brother
man i'm all in on you guys good for you
um i'm all in let me know how it goes
let me know how those hard conversations
go and keep me updated man
let us know when the baby's born and
we'll keep thinking about you all in
your journey
all right hey let's uh let's take a
quick break
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do in anxiety
or panic strikes like a lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's take one more call let's
go to kelsey in columbus ohio hey kelsey
good morning how are you
hi i'm good how are you outstanding
what's going on how can i help
um well i have a four-year-old with my
ex
and he recently moved to a different
state
and then filed for custody after not
really contributing
the last three years um the custody
issue has really put a strain on me and
i'm
wondering how i go about maintaining my
mental health
through this while continuing
supporting my son and his relationship
with his dad yeah what a mess i'm so
sorry
what a mess um so first things first
is he gonna win custody it sounds like a
like a
like this isn't gonna go anywhere i mean
if he's got a back a history of
three or four years of not paying child
support and not being present
no one's gonna take him away from you um
to a new state unless you've got stuff
going on in your life
so tell me about the chances of him
winning this this custody suit
um the chances are low um
i never really necessarily worried
that he would win it's just
the whole mess of dealing with the
lawyer
dealing with the strain he's put on
everybody because it's involved you know
his whole family i have to get like
witnesses
and it's like the whole process of it
that is so mentally draining and i'm
also a full-time student
in college um so
it's it's the whole mental strain of the
whole process that's really
killing me awesome i mean not awesome
but i appreciate you
i appreciate you clairing clarifying
that for me
um all right so tell me about this
little boy
he's pretty rad yes he's awesome
tell me about him um so he's really
funny
he has a great personality his smile is
magnetic
everybody seems to love him and think
he's hilarious everywhere we go
and he just is like a huge light in
everyone's life
so he's pretty fantastic
so you told me about how everybody else
feels about him how do you feel about
him
oh my gosh he's my whole world
um i love him so much everything i do is
for him
um and he's
brought a lot of meaning to my life so i
mean i don't know what i would
be without him awesome
so have you in the past struggle with
mental health challenges or is this
all new for you are you just feeling
overwhelmed all of a sudden
i've struggled for most of my life with
mental health
challenges like what
anxiety mostly depression
my family has a history of mental
illness too
so i've seen that all my life are you
actively taking care of yourself
i just started therapy last week which
is
really overdue but i'm glad that i
finally did it
good for you you deserve that your son
deserves that
and this life you're building together
is going to be um greatly facilitated by
you by you taking that step take care of
yourself so i'm proud of you i know
that's hard
hard hard hard um so at the end of the
day
here's where you are okay and i know you
know this but i'm just going to say it
out loud and walk you through it
sometimes having somebody just
pull things apart for us pretty easy
pretty simply and just laying it out
there
it can help a little bit okay so
this is an old saying you may have heard
me say 100 times on the show
not by your hand but in your lap what
does that mean
that means that somebody just set your
house on fire
and you're in the front yard watching it
burn you didn't
like this match you didn't um
you didn't fill the house up with
gasoline somebody else did it
but now you're in the front yard and you
have
only one choice which is to go put the
fire out right
and so when i am faced with a situation
like this in my life
there's three things that i know
ultimately keep me well
okay number one is having other people
in my life being connected relationships
number two is really working hard to
control my thoughts which is what
therapy teaches you to do
and the other one is controlling what i
can control when it comes to my actions
right and at the end of the day that's
it
and what anxiety tries to do is
number one it's an alarm that lets you
know you're disconnected from other
people
right you're in a situation where you're
not safe or you're in a situation where
you feel out of control
right nothing would make me feel more
out of control than somebody who i used
to love and i used to trust
filing for a court order to take my
child away from me and move to another
state
that sounds terrifying to me i don't
like my daughter and my wife were out of
town recently
i don't like them my daughter being gone
a couple of days right
so can you honestly sit there for a
second and just put both hands down by
your lap
and just go somebody trying to take my
kid away
just say that out loud
right now yeah right now just say it
someone's trying to take my kid away
okay
if that's not a um
that's not a good reason for your body
to sound the alarms i don't know what is
right so your anxiety in this moment is
warranted and it's right and it's good
it means your brain's working just fine
right
and then if you have an anxious brain
like i do you start dreaming about all
the scenarios all of the things
all of the what-ifs and could bees and
oh my gosh and
then this is and that's right do you
spin off and just head off into the
woods
oh yeah yes exactly and why do we do
that
because we're not gonna actually fight
or flee in real life we're just gonna do
it in our heads
right and we're gonna fight and flee all
over the place how many imaginary
conversations do you have with your
ex-husband that you'll never have in
person
um a dozen a day
[Laughter]
does it solve anything ever no
it just makes it worse i know right so
much worse
okay so here's what you're gonna do you
ready
it's so simple and super hard okay
the first thing you're gonna do is this
you're gonna get some people in your
corner
do you have a friend there your mom
there
besides a therapist you have somebody
you can trust
yeah you didn't you didn't answer that
very confidently
um no i do um my brothers are supportive
and
um my ex's family are actually really
supportive of me so
okay so let's lean on your brothers
because court is going to make them have
to choose and that's going to get messy
so i want you to reach out to your
brothers today and let them know
that you are taking some active steps to
be proactive and handle this deal
this custody suit is going to be a mess
they're going to want every text message
and email
and like you said witnesses there's
gonna be drama on top of drama on top of
drama
i want you to let them know you have
designated them
as the guys in your corner and you're
gonna call them at weird hours of the
night you're going to send them text
messages that say it's all coming down
and their job is to write back and say
it's not and we love you
okay but let them know that they're
going to be your right or die don't just
assume it
and two things are going to happen one
if they're good brothers like i know
they are they're gonna puff their chest
out and say yeah that's what's up
and your brain is gonna go okay we got
people
it's gonna check that mark off right
and then the second thing i want you to
begin making a daily list this is
something what you do every day
of what are the things you can control
today
right okay the things that are spinning
out in your head
write all that write it all down but
you're gonna go down that list and say
what can i control today
so you might write down he might um this
is a list of your fears sorry i should
have said that your fears your anxieties
i want you to write all that stuff down
get it out of your head
on a piece of paper not the computer
either by the way number one they'll
subpoena that but number two
there's something kinetic about writing
with your hand it gets
tiring it's frustrating it's it's it's
it's you get mad when you're just
writing and writing
but i want you to write down a piece of
paper this guy is trying to take my kid
can i control that nope he's trying
number two i have to get all this
paperwork done
can i control that yep i'm just gonna
put on a to-do list and just get that
done i'm not gonna
be anxious about it i'm not gonna fight
it that's a thing i can do i'm gonna i
can control that i'm gonna move on
number three an old friend of mine is
now dating this guy and they move to
whatever
now i'm just making this stuff up
because it's my show and that's kind of
fun for me
you can write down i can't control that
right number four
i love my son and not a day will go by
that he doesn't know that he's the most
important thing that ever happened to me
can i control that
yep i'm exhausted
can i go exercise and then go to sleep
can i control that yep
i'm feeling lonely and starting to spit
out can i reach out to my friends can i
control that
yep i got a crap ton of homework to do
can i control that
yep right and so what you're going to do
is you're going to slowly start
dwindling down all these crazy thoughts
that are spinning like a saw blade in
your mind
to just a list of a few things that you
can control and most of them are going
to be about you taking care of yourself
taking care of your body taking care of
your head and knocking these tasks
off and then the final thing is you're
going to work with this counselor
on how to begin to control your thoughts
and i'm looking at you
i can't see you but i'm looking into
this camera here i
promise with practice you can begin to
control your thoughts
sometimes my wife laughs me because
laughs at me because i'm walking through
the living room and she'll just hear me
go nope
and she'll just smile because she knows
i just had an intrusive thought pop in
my head about a worst case scenario
thing that could happen or not happen
and i just say nope and then i
immediately have another go-to thought
like that time my kid did a funny thing
or how much i love my folks
or that time me and my brother were
messing with reindeer on a cruise
whatever the thing happens to be
i've got things ready to go and over
time you begin to practice and you take
more and more ownership of your thoughts
and then that those times when the
depression kicks in and you think
this is my fault this is always going to
be this way
then you've got this new reservoir of
strength in your mind that says
no it's not and let's go exercise
no it's not let's go call my brother
we're going to go for a walk no it's not
i got one more paper to write and then
i'm done for the semester no it's not
i'm gonna go grab a couple of
girlfriends from my class and we're
gonna go get some coffee
and with depression you take those
little steps with anxiety
you reach out with anxiety you write
down what you can control and not
control with anxiety
you begin to work on controlling your
thoughts
and suddenly you're going to look up in
a year this suit is going to be
dismissed on its marriage it's a waste
of time
or they're going to go through the
rigamaroo and make sure that he never
does this again
you're going to re you're going to have
more strength
you're going to be well you're going to
be have connection
you're going to be graduating and then
honey your whole life is ahead of you
and you're going to take those bricks
out of your backpack and you're going to
pave a road that you and your kid are
going to walk on
and the people you never have met before
are going to walk on
it's what redeeming all those pains
looks like man this is legacy this is
you building a road moving forward
but it starts with man getting connected
controlling what you can control letting
the other crap go
and then doing the hard work of
practicing practicing practicing
controlling your thoughts
thank you so much for that call kelsey
man we'll be thinking about you let us
know how the court case goes
it's probably gonna get dismissed quite
honestly but let us know how it goes
and as we wrap up today's show
it was probably 83 84 93q
an old houston rock station
back when richard marx was rock
that's my best joke of today of his 1989
repeat offender album the first time i
knew a song could give me goosebumps
and make me fall in love not to anybody
but just
to love itself this
is the greatest song ever written and if
you're out there just drinking the
haterade
oh philly on you off the 1989 repeat
offender album richard marks
in his classic love song right here
waiting and it goes like this
this is so good ocean's apart day after
day and i slowly go insane
i hear your voice on the line but what
but it doesn't stop the pain
if i see you next to never how can we
save forever
it's a good question richard wherever
you go
whatever you do i'll be right here
waiting for you
whatever it takes or how my heart breaks
i will be right here waiting for you
oh can't you see it baby you've got me
going crazy
wherever you go this is the dr john
dolone show
[Music]
you